bella tutti ragazzi è venuto questo
video sono tanto su residenti vr free un
remake a chi non vedo l'ora di nella
terra né vero non vedo l'ora di finirla
vorrei che durasse per sempre però i
colpi non sono infiniti purtroppo buona
visione
ma devo usare lui davvero adesso di fate
uno switch di parma come ma cosa carlos
sarebbe la claire di residenti oltre
quindi la claire nel senso di vita alla
fine ska dio cioè poliziotto del 2 ma
come scusa
prego chi ha parlato no [ __ ] ecco
come l'hanno morso si è fatto prendere
dal fatto che ha parlato ecco perché è
stato morso allora maledizione entriamo
quale entrò no porca vacca un questo è
veramente il caso debba quindi rimasto
tutto uguale hanno ripreso la stessa
zona parte a verde nobilissimo passare
esattamente quello che ho pensato a casa
due ragazzi uguale occhio i coach cini
linker questo casino
[Musica]
boukris ban che cazzo è da quella roba
lì che riprende è veramente a questo poi
proprio uso e così come è morto lo
zombie con del del 2 ma darebbe il
massimo è tutto così allegro andiamo
questo le porte a quadri fuoco io non
devo praticamente sto rivivendo una zona
del 2 ma
ma fino a un certo punto perché comunque
la fine le porte quelle quadrifoglio e
non le possa aprire salve
allora usa burroughs tre secondi corri
ma come l'ima esci la stanza almeno una
bella dopo lui si fida tranquillo
permesso minchia no che è successo a mi
chiamo fossero suo posto torna indietro
porca [ __ ] raga un fatto veramente del
mio meglio quanta gente tutti qua erano
video tutti qua pieno di zombie tutti
dietro il muro madonna ragazzi di colpi
degli m4 altro veloce perfetto saranno
ancora tutti vivi sono storditi io amato
dai ragazzi
non gli ho dato la spallata santo di dio
è niente neri a loro modo non o moto non
regalava sono macchine sono veramente
morti sono morti sono morti sono morti
sono morti morti sono
mi sono misurato sulla roma che sono
morto sono morto sono morte sono morte
sono molto sono morto tutto ok
o come ho fatto a sopra impossibile non
posso essere sopravvissuto davvero non
ci credo che culo che culo infinito
[Musica]
bella la foto del cane può trovare
qualcuno tranquillo la tireremo fuori mi
dice dove si trova sono in campo nato in
un [ __ ] ospedale circondato da mostri
di ogni genere allora sapranno valutare
negativo larghi di è stato invaso lui
entrato come se niente fosse
questo ci fosse lì che fuori è una
soluzione
beh simpatico comunque qua c'è una cassa
oggetti ma non c'è cosa per salvare
orribile in un momento del genere
orribile devo salvare perché come esco
muoio prova dai lo trovo un cazzo bravo
bravo bravo come che succede che sei
morgan e allora che comunque ci sono
feriti ma il treno che aspetta cosa jill
jill che succede gil e rispondi
vi devo andare
no problem penso io a parte
le 450 del mattino cioè 4 43
meraviglioso
andiamo al treno alle 4 del mattino
comunque sei uscito nel corridoio come
si sente fosse spero che tu sia tornata
al treno
meno male meno male perché sennò ugazzi
a miasmi chat ok ok ok ma al 18
personaggio
allegria torna in superficie quanto
abbia fatto tra l'altro il tuo sto
casino
mica ti lamenti con my wellness meno
male sono tornato con le mie armi perché
vi giuro concarneau segue io lo odio
odio la m4 perché non fa niente
c'è proprio tutto figo che continui a
sparare ma in realtà non sta levando
nulla quindi lo detesto per visto la
pistola veramente quindi le mie armi
cielo luri timbrate permesso con rai o
di un successo carlos questi non
riescono a parlarsi normalmente 1
nessuno dai dai che mi accogliesti cosi
che solo preso bene mine di prossimità e
munizioni aspetta esplodono dopo un
certo periodo di tempo se rilevano dei
movimenti all'interno delle loro raggio
d'azione figo bella parola
let's go madonna quanti siete nelle
fogne e ma dio cosa stavate facendo un
rave party nelle fogne prima di prendere
di astori rus che cacchio
va bene che questo sia alzamento
scommetto che ormai non mi fido più di
nessuno faccio scattini appena vede uno
fermo la superficie e milano centrale
come un naviglio bastarda ancora vivo e
non certo dal creativo ma fu ma dov'è ma
perché l'hai visto l'hai sentito hai
sentito il rumore verso el'asta zona
raga che figo stagione bellissima
grazie sapete che vorranno venire di un
altra roba ancora più liberi lenti vol
io vorrei remake ragazzi di daino crisis
avete mai sentito dai no cry this
ragazzi se facessero remake ed è quello
sarei ancora più contento bello stop o
ampera gaspero non crolli per colpa del
nemesis
io l'ho scritto io sto jones neanche mia
non ho mai giocato in tre io mai è
successo è andato a fuoco
che culo che c'aveva d'acqua
disposizione poi anche io l'ho
risulterei in questo momento soprattutto
mentre c'è un ponte lunghissimo che dove
potrebbe succedere di tutto
ce l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo deragliato
no sono morti sono tutti morti
mikhail tutti quanti mikhail se lo
meritava però io stato nicolaiano era
nicolais usava corri
a queste quando 78 carlos dalla chiamata
bene è successa questa cosa questa non
ha ancora capito dopo tutto sto board ea
ma sono io che corto ero io che correvo
non avevo capito che sono sul filmato
ok a testo è diventato più grosso sono
io passo diventano dei grossi prima ma
comunque ragazzi incredibile che questa
ancora non abbia capito che tu non lo
puoi felice non lo puoi uccidere quindi
basta pensare che sia morto ogni tre per
due
e morto secondo me invece è ancora in
circolazione
ma basta no non ci credo un altro post
fai un'altra aero tu vai ragazzo fu
lanciato la granata e non dovevo
lanciarla io lo sapevo
datemi dei proiettili ai proventi di
qualsiasi progetto di qualsiasi prendi
qualsiasi porca vacca picchia le mine
che ho preso prima servono a questo
immagino madonna non saprò mai votato la
testata la portiera moro
buono mi sa che questo devo sparare
mentre si avvicina
la donna schiva ed io qua è un problema
mi sa che dato ciò le cure più o meno
sono anche messo ben arturo tradizione
non ho però non è talmente grossa la
statura che non capiscono sono i
proiettili ce n'è uno lì per terra non
l'ha preso però nel dubbio il dubbio
dispari faccia ragazzi continua così che
non finisco tutti i proiettili
incendiari voi basta ya forme quanto c'è
andato vicino qua
e morto non muore
tanto il dio non ho più colpi mi servono
quelli di prima questi esatto cosa fa e
poi cosa succede cosa faccio quasi ti
siedi si accendono di certo non è umano
zia scena ce la faccio di sparo lo
guardo ci gioco a carte cosa faccio
farò tutto perché una sostanza quello
scemo
l'ho colpito grande dai dai bravissima
come l'ho colpito bene adesso non l'ho
colpito bene è bellissima la mia di
prossimità e bellissimo angolo correre
mi ha colpito subito sì bellissima la
mia di possibilità è fatta veramente
bene
problema che devo curarmi sono schiatto
ragazzi come siamo messi non voglio
esaminare l'erba con vino ai proiettili
minchia che giornata di mer e no no no
no non ho più i eccoli qua invece veloce
ed è invincibile hanno fortemente
ricorda combinano no chi non sapeva fare
digiuno sono allo stremo nato sono più
linee di possibilità anni fa niente la
pistola è come se stiamo dando le
caramelle ma questa caramella ecco è
piaciuto lega rame il meno male quale mi
sto morendo più bello è che non me la
sto giocando nemmeno male perché ho
schivato lynskey va bill e cioè non già
promette a fare una partita dove schifo
così tanto quindi se non dico adesso
è che cacchio
ma proprio negli allievi il fucino
riserva anni non sembra niente si colpi
amica niente al nulla capitana non ho
più cure sono praticamente morto mi sto
guardando in giro per adesso ci sono
altri altre linee ma vediamo se lo
diceva mappa dalla mappa dice che non ho
più niente da trovare perfetto quindi ho
finito tutto il trovabile e devo farlo
devo farlo con le armi che ogni inutile
completamente porca vacca ragazzi
non ho neanche più cura e quindi devo
muovermi cielo ancora alcune 9 ce l'ho
fatta mi chiami meno male non avevo più
niente ragazzi la fai finta di avere
ancora forti che non ce li hai
robert
carlos è morto aspetta non lo è
guarda lo sapevo è l'esordio dice di
volte e adesso che ti dovevi vantare di
averlo ucciso finalmente che non si
rialzerà mai più meno braga sono pi
niente non avevo più niente meno male
meno male ma non c'è più nulla in giro
che culo perché ho lasciato le mine di
prima lo lasciate nel morto è sicuro è
morto sicuramente morto non si rialzerà
mai più a posto neanche hai fatto un
mezzo al cancello il cancello sbarra
cancello farà cancello brava farai
cancello
[Musica]
esatto ecco avrei fatto anche ieri che
il suo gioco sono veramente non strada
ma prevedo tutto cazzo che male se tieni
è stato qualcosa se nella merda e mi sa
di sì
meno male che non può raggiungere questo
ancora vi questo qua come fai a essere
l'iter mi hai davvero fatto un grande
favore
ma tra l'altro a lui non lo uccide
schifo meno note ma lui non lo uccide
per lui non è niente carlos aperto dal
nulla risponde a un cazzo mi riceve
diano veramente no no no succede gilet
infetta ora la porto all'ospedale forse
il dottor parte poco si arriva mente non
so cosa dire ragazzi questa arrivato in
corsa e cacchio 6 mag e di omino
incredibile poi tra l'altro il posto
casinò mentre c'era il nemesis che non
appagato per niente dimitri york slam
come si chiama con l'altro la regola
avete di mitra o si è detto
l'ospedale il modo migliore per passare
il dato è sicuramente
non ci saranno gli zombie in giro quindi
vai tranquillo ed al dottore
no non mi far cominciare su carlos tino
ti prego perché non ce la faccio aiutare
dove si trova ecco deve essere nel
laboratorio nel laboratorio si perché io
so come funziona quasi tutta la mappa
c'erano in testa a baila certo
minchia mi sono cagato addosso ma fa
niente facciamo finta di nulla come se
niente fosse
ciao a è morto chi è che l'ha lanciato
così era accaduto di di sua sponte si è
lanciato senza testa e basta ammesso che
non ho chiuso si alza a mille per cento
erano oppure sia il sera quando tornerò
a che però la voce del dottor bard
sicuro madonella bier in tosto posto e
lo sapevo lo sapevo allora santo iddio
senza sicura proiettili everywhere
proiettili e brewer meno male ragazza
promesso mari fa che di proiettili non
avevo più per la mia almeno la pistola
che decente
meno male l'ex save the game ma dove c'è
un sacco dvd cure con carlo si fece con
giovanna non avevo neanche mezzo la
perfetta ei ragazzi finisco qua
l'episodio number freni il residence ivo
cv dare un posto episodio iscrivetevi
cliccate il tasto mi piace che mi
supportate e di sopportate soprattutto
per noi come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]